like everyone and prep slightly earlier
than some started noticing not so much
the opioid crisis which is white people
dying but the problem of addiction and
just how widespread it was and it
clearly was getting more widespread and
there seemed to be some relation to that
and the the loss of jobs especially sort
of middle class or slightly lower men
and that's Angus Deaton than the
statistics and so forth and it it felt
kind of familiar to me it reminded me of
Russia mm-hmm we're under the Soviets
there were people just doing useless
jobs and drinking themselves to death I
asked one of my friends I said you know
you shouldn't smoke and drink so much
because you're gonna die early and he
said well life is not so wonderful that
we really care about that you know
better to drink now and be happy
the women tended to deal with it much
better because for two reasons one they
had children and they felt they were
important in some of these lives than
they had a purpose and also they took
the money that both they and their
husbands earned and they went and stood
on line and turned the money into things
that they valued the money itself was
useless and the jobs were purchase so I
started reading about addiction and if
anybody wants there was Gabor maté a
there was Maya salivates who wrote a
book called the unbroken brain I think
why yeah addiction is not a character
defect you said it was a learning
disorder and then I read the book that I
thought made the most sense called the
biology of desire by a guy called Mark
Lewis and he really said that it was
learning from disorder in other words
if you fundamentally if you start your
life out with a lack of security with
unpredictable parents with basically if
your brain is damaged during the first
few years of life you become vulnerable
later on and there's there's lots of
stuff now that have adverse childhood
experiences and there's a clear
correlation between adverse early
childhood experiences and addiction
obesity dropping out of school abusing
your own children ending up in jail and
so forth and so on
so mark Lewis who is himself it was
formerly addicted tells the story of
five people and towards the end he says
I don't really know what my next book is
going to be about but one way or another
is about time and in a sense
foreshortening
you you lose you lose your peripheral
vision you're focused only on this thing
you desire that you're never satiated
you you reach for it that's the moment
of desire you get it and you're almost
immediately back into the cycle you lose
a sense of time you lose your past that
was different you lose a sense of agency
I can have a future that's different
he talked about Native Americans the
ones who had lost their sense of history
are much more subject to alcohol abuse
and all those familiar problems so I
went to see him in the Netherlands where
he lives and this time thing and this
short cycle we need dopamine we need
desire to live we won't do anything if
we don't have a desire but if your
desire is only short-term and instant it
it becomes addiction whether it's yeah I
used to think this this thing about cell
phone addiction was
just like yeah yeah that's a clever
metaphor but not really but in fact
addiction is a behavior pattern it's it
can be if you're addicted to a substance
that actually has bad physical effects
like alcohol in particular or drugs that
it's worse but it's it's the behavior
pattern and that short that
foreshortened cycle of wanting something
that doesn't actually provide the relief
you're seeking much more than it is the
substance that's really at the heart of
addiction and the trick is how do you
change that short term desire which is
addiction into long term desire which is
purpose where there is a sense of the
future and of change and of getting some
gratification that's long-term
impermanent
so let me ask you I think there are some
people who would say the solution is
individual a person has to make good
choices they are responsible for yeah a
day there are agents of their own
fortune addiction is a moral failing
personal and then there are other people
who'd say no it's a structural problem
it's a collective problem right people
may not have choices all of their
choices may be bad their environment may
be constraining their choices right and
they're not making a stupid choice if
you have no job why not go out and get
drunk
you'll feel better or why not it's the
only job in your community is to deal
drugs then you'll deal drugs if it's the
most lucrative thing right yeah and
that's that's different from addiction I
mean the best drug dealers are not
addicted they're smart business people
but but the point is that your
environment gives you certain incentives
choices yes mate and they can only shoes
you can only make the choices that you
have to make and so no I think I mean
you can get into long discussions but
fundamentally how many of you were AI
people yeah yeah if you need a better
training set for infant brains
we've trained our AIS we need to figure
out how to train our children's brains
not with training but yep train them
that your mother loves you and that life
is not totally secure but your parents
love you and they'll take care of you
and you need to give them a sense of
security so that they can trust in the
long term in a sense addiction is you've
lost trust in everything but this
immediate short-term source of Solace
[Music]